the uh the other issue that that i think
is relevant now that the contracts are
all in drew brees
25 million this year from the saints
philip rivers 25 million this year from
the colts tom brady 25 million this year
from the buccaneers all three of these
quarterbacks two of them first ballot
hall of famers one i think you can make
the argument whether or not he even gets
in in rivers
25 million across the board which guy's
the best value
oh
i um you know i
river they all have interesting things
about them and strengths and weaknesses
about their game you know river is just
his carelessness with the football is
scary so i'm not going to put him
there with brady and breeze now rivers
is also the guy that can make some big
plays so if he can find that governor or
that you know a line in the sand to say
okay let's not step over that because
that's when i get crazy you know he can
still be effective just like these other
guys i i still go i'm gonna go with tom
brady you know it's close between him
and drew brees but i just look at brady
and i still think his arm is top-notch i
think he's got the weapons around him i
think he's got an offense and a support
staff that's really going to build
something special around him as well let
alone let him infuse some of his
offensive ideas and things he did in new
england so i'm going to give brady the
slight edge there you know one of the
dynamics as well and i i can't remember
who wrote this yesterday it may have
been peter king the idea that or you may
have said it chris i don't know the
information is coming from so many
different angles the idea that tom brady
will have a lasting influence on the
organization if he's there two years
he can influence enough of his teammates
in those two years that even after he's
gone kind of the fumes of his attitude
his work ethic his approach to
everything from diet to exercise to
preparation all of that could linger
beyond him especially if they have a
quarterback who succeeds tom brady who
gets a chance to learn the ropes from
him and maybe that's one of the things
they'll do maybe they draft a guy this
year or next year but it's it's it's a
way to upgrade an organization you know
if you can get that tom brady influence
to take root in your locker room no
doubt he can lay down the the train
tracks to
show a team young players what it takes
to be successful uh you hear that all
the time i mean it's infectious with
star players when they come into town
you know and then also it just shows
young players the way you know i can
remember tim brown coming to where the
hall of fame receiver from the raiders
coming to our tampa bay team and you
know young receivers just gravitated
towards them especially after practice
because he was going to do a few drills
and do a few things that he felt like
made him a better player and all of a
sudden you notice that every receiver on
the team's doing that after practice so
that is what a great player can do for
an organization and especially an
organization that doesn't have players
that have ever come from a winning
environment or know what it takes to get
to a super bowl and do that they can
think they're working hard or they're
dedicated but then they see a guy like
brady and they go damn okay i need to
raise my game here i thought i was
working hard but i'm really kind of just
giving a b-minus effort brady is what i
need to do and i can see he's obsessed
and he lives it and this is all he does
all day every day and that's what makes
him special and i think that will you
know wear off on a lot of guys in that
locker room point you made yesterday
that we need to emphasize again today
because i thought it was an excellent
observation the idea that some teams
weren't interested in tom brady because
they didn't want to be exposed when
brady comes to town and looks around and
says well i know why this team stinks
because it's a far cry from the work and
the effort and the ingenuity and the
creativity that the patriots bring to
the organization every single day and
wouldn't that have been something afraid
to go somewhere and there's a
conversation at some point between brady
and the owner about why the team didn't
thrive and brady says well you got a
long way to go to be like new england
and i think a lot of coaches out there
who aren't the patriots would probably
like to conceal that those specifics
those reasons from their owners chris
no no no doubt you know again the
patriots it's a special place we know
brady's special but the environment the
culture the coaches that are up there in
new england they're outside the box
thinking their attention to detail
in all facets of their organization is
on another level and yeah brady's gonna
go to tampa and as much respect as i
have for everybody in tampa there he's
still gonna look at it and go okay this
is in new england i'm having fun and i
love it uh but he's gonna realize
there's there's definitely a different
way of doing business and maybe it's not
quite as you know top-notch as what bill
belichick is doing there in new england
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports